hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the last stand
the last stand is one of my favourite
games of the entire flash and when I say
flash game you'll look at this and you
won't even think of a flash game because
it's so well made and even considering
its time which I think it was made oh
seven is even more amazing I remember
how to play the game correctly now and I
can guide you through this game but I
highly recommend playing it for yourself
I mean sure watch this video I love you
guys for watching these videos but this
game is one that even after you watch it
you should play this game so the last
stand
I finished the wall today it should hold
them off for a while I hope tomorrow I
better look for survivors and something
better to protect myself with I have to
get through the night first WASD space
escape aim shoot kill kill so this game
takes a lot of clicking dexterity at
least in the beginning of the game when
you don't exactly have any of the better
stuff and this first pistol ain't
nothing too good
and those zombo's are coming hot and
fast and actually even for the time and
I do say I said this before but this
game is running way faster than my
original computer that I played this on
granted because back in the day this
used to be like the cutting edge of what
flash could even do so I didn't do too
well in that one but I need to dedicate
all of my time in the beginning to
searching for weapons because you can
either search for survivors or you can
search for weapons or you can repair
your barricade I don't even need to
worry about repairing my barricade right
now because I'm a 91% but looking for
survivors is actually a bit of a foolish
adventure because their survivors don't
help initially because you don't have
that many weapons you want to upgrade
your weapons because getting the better
weapons right away is super important in
the long run see right now I found a 351
people lost from search parties I was by
myself who could have been lost
I was literally alone did I die I don't
know what that's about and also the
diary moves forward every single day so
it worked well it worked fairly well it
didn't fall out on its own is what I
mean they're still just as slow as the
others I've seen don't seem to make the
jump to get over the wall
yeah it's only ankle-high they can't
quite make it so but the zombies do get
a lot more difficult towards the end of
this game and it becomes very
challenging what juggling your reload
times juggling aim and I mean the aim is
a little bit you know unpredictable just
generally because it's like there's some
randomness to exactly the location of
the bullets but if you're good enough I
think the trick I remember was aiming a
little bit item because the the cone of
spread is like based entirely on the I
think it's the location so like if it's
closer up your your shots are actually
gonna splay more so you gotta aim like
if I recall the strategy I played the
crap out of this game I mean I played
this game relentlessly when I was first
trying this it is such a cool game and I
think that the weapon meter is linear so
each time you dedicate 12 hours you're
going to find another weapon which is
good and which is also good because I'm
pretty sure I'm not 100% sure but I'm
pretty sure that you can actually assign
weapons to survivors unless that's
another game just like on TV I'm
shooting them in the head like the TV
said seems to stop them quick enough
they don't have an explanation for
what's happening though I don't know how
you're watching TV there's entire hordes
of zombies out there it's gotta be no
one left I don't even remember if I read
the story much when I was first playing
this game but this is an amazing game
it's such a I didn't equip my pump Liz
where I could die I could I could
actually die on this one just because
I didn't do it right yeah yeah okay
get away get away get away I don't want
any Girl Scout cookies hello anything oh
oh please I don't need to hear the good
word come on it's so hard to hit him in
the head is missing when they're bunched
up like that we go sorry
oh is that Ray Charles I'm sorry oh okay
so the next weapon is I believe the
shotgun which is something that I
definitely need once I get the shock and
I should be able to do oh no oh no I
don't know why I didn't equip the UMP
before but that was stupid to me okay
cop killer kill the cop today not sure
how I feel about that all's fair I guess
he dropped a revolver that might come in
handy though I still need more hands
around here to get anything done should
look for more survivors in the morning
yeah I'm kind of by myself
all alone no one to hold me in the world
so cold at night
yeah survivors don't actually help all
that is much better
it took me a while to realize because
you actually need to start shooting
again each time after you reload which
requires like I did another click it
takes more time and you got to predict
exactly when your reloads gonna end and
then you got to be quick about the
headshot
and these bigger people you know they
don't exactly go down as easily that's
all a big crisis and my walls about
spring oh god he's getting bad
I shouldn't I should have gotten some
survivors some survivors would have been
a great help
oh yes cuz I think I think I'm gonna get
the shotgun anyway I think the shotgun
is actually given to me in like the next
one so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
look for a lot of survivors and then I'm
gonna do all survivors I'm putting a big
risk here because if I don't fall Kat
found two survivors so I or not dogs
whatever it is that's causing this it's
not restricted to humans huge stinking
Rottweilers seem to be affected too
man I hate dogs I don't I love dogs not
when they're trying to eat me but you
know it's all the same get away get away
get away head shots LSATs I'm too good
for you I'm too good I'm diggin
I know the TV reporter they done gone
away I don't mean gone away I mean they
they came right to me they didn't
exactly go anywhere at all in fact they
turned into zombies and then decided to
cover the main story of the survivors
that were encamped out in the middle of
the woods in nowhere
I'm sure hope that's Yami's don't come
up behind us yeah that's true man oh god
that's oh god oh no oh no oh no that one
was hard to hit I don't know why oh this
is getting dicey here all just getting
really dicey but I think I'm gonna make
it through this night and I was wrong I
wasn't gonna get a shotgun in this
particular one that was gonna be a
little bit later so now I need to find a
lot more survivors because I think I'm
definitely gonna get the shotgun in this
one repair it up pretty good give it
about sixty would do fine and then look
for more survivors please don't lose
anyone yes yes
okay got more survivors which is gonna
help me a lot okay this just in pretty
sure I topped the local roving reporter
wonder if I'll make the news tonight
well probably not considering that all
civilization seems to be hitting the
[ __ ] no Ho Chi no see okay they do
that better some of them do have
revolvers ah their shotgun man so that's
the shotgun which is fine
okay so when you have the shotgun you
always want the shotgun to be your
backup because the shotgun is powerful
but it has a hell of a reload time so
you won't be able to like turn around
and start getting shots out much quicker
like the pump grill when the ups not all
that powerful but it does turn around on
the reloads pretty quickly so like this
I've got this pretty well master oh
sorry I think that was my elementary
school teacher for mrs. Bachmann no I
can't believe okay
anyway so now what that did for me is
what uh what that did for me is that
jumped ahead my next search for weapons
so that there I'm able to get ahead on
the weapon game and because the next one
is a chainsaw
what Oh No I've been doing it wrong
okay that's fine all right fat farm
these fat bastards are all over the
place
welcome to America they seem to take way
more punishment than the others need
something with a bit more kick to finish
them off which is why I have the shotgun
and hopefully some of my dudes will be
able to get that don't know though it's
not fair it's not fair I tells you I
mean everything seems to be under
control like it's going way better than
the last game was because I was not
strategized properly for it I mean you
can see why this game was obviously one
of my favorites and the guy in Vegas or
the people that made this we're just
like way ahead of their time
in terms of this because there's just a
lot of elements go ahead why was it
gonna fire where does that guy come from
Lennie little this is a lot of things
going on in this game that are really
advanced that you don't obviously see
those zombies are actually randomly
generated they're taking piecemeal from
different clothing sets and they're put
together in a certain way
which is really cool and Oh any
searching give me dangerous one the
green am I gonna oh come on
for a chainsaw what a bunch of baloney
ah let's see oh great now the fatties
are running great well I didn't see any
of them running that's good then right
but I want to make fun of them that'd be
really mean I mean they may be zombies
but they're people too
in the world of zombies there's no time
for emotions no time pinnacle Ricky's
it's so easy to start clicking before
the clippings ready to click Oh God okay
get off of my lawn get off of my lawn Oh
God
there we go that did something I don't
know if it actually helped me it made me
feel good about my life and that's all
the really matters when you're facing
the zombie apocalypse so long as you're
feeling life I guess that's an objective
because everything else is resulting in
death oh thank you
sorry about your eye not doing well okay
I need to find another weapon no matter
what I gotta get that weapon so I'm just
gonna dedicate all and then hopefully
the next weapon is a sawn-off yes that's
great that is good that is actually
really really good and I'm actually
gonna put the chainsaw as the backup
because if they get close and I can just
shear them all off but I remember the
the sawed-off shotgun is actually fun um
cuz it's quick reload huge stopping
power especially if you hit him nope
this is not going well for me
just walk into my blades please the
sawed-off shotgun has you loads of
stopping power just doodles and oodles
stopping power hunting rifle I don't
know if that's good I'm gonna try it
this might be the end of me but hey
actually I'm gonna switch this wedge cuz
just in case I can't remember founding
rifle he is good or not oh this is good
Wow sure wish I could hit something
okay the hunting rifle is definitely
good oh we could Pierce 200 no oh yes oh
yes oh yes hunting rifle is amazing
Oh hunting rifle is good oh thank you
yours hunting rifle is amazing so now
I'm just gonna focus on getting this
barrier up and then looking for more
survivors okay we got five survivors and
no one died on that last one so that
should be good they're onto me Oh Oh had
a visit from the bassam be police guess
they heard about me killing everyone
oh wow that's a lot of bullets I don't
know if there's any better than the oh
yeah that's not better than you oh god
oh god they're building up oh god oh god
oh god this is not good oh no oh no this
is not what I was supposed to be doing
TV so much for contact at the outside
the TV reception disappeared last night
guess they finally got into the station
looks like this might be it
soon anyway okay I don't like the sound
of that
it sounds way too final for my tastes
okay let's just do this because with the
hunting rifle I can do no wrong do no
wrong I'm like the sniper from tf2 with
reloading these bullets like one at a
time I gotta be like blazing fast with
this I mean if this is all you did like
all day every day is like move around
and scope headshots from I guess is not
too far but I guess you get pretty good
at reloading after a while there we go
it's getting pretty good my clicking
finger is tired that's why I remember my
clicking finger was so beat up before
running low we've exhausted pretty much
all the food in the area why did I
choose somewhere so far from the cities
yes we need to make the decision to move
or not it's just getting so dangerous
you got damn right it is
come on you're damn dirty Apes zombies
whatever same thing Oh No what if zombie
Apes just keep from the zoo no no it'd
be like Planet of the Apes all over
again except Planet of the zone beeps
planet of the 2/8 AP's plant planet of a
bees Oh No Abe Lincoln is written from
the dead oh yeah
suppose your nice lovely heads for my
bullets please standard zombie procedure
is to run face first into my gun and
then prover Bleen out try to bite me
just try to Pike the end of my gun
that'll be good enough for everybody
involved
mm buzzer found two we're up to six and
I got an ake a bet that won't be
anywhere near as good as what I've got
here
oh no the diary I forgot I'm sorry I'm a
failure I'm sorry well would you look at
that it's just as bad oh god no not at
the end not here not now
no why did I switch to the a K why why
god damn that did not go well me the
army seems the military presence here
are all dead we've started making
preparations to get out of here okay
will do yeah I'm pretty sure I'm not a
hundred percent sure on that one but I'm
pretty sure that if you keep hunting for
weapons oh my god a clown oh no what if
he was just running away from the
zombies and trying to be happy oh why
did his why did his clown nose not honk
right as he got shot oh that would have
been so tragically hilarious it's
actually really cool because I didn't
even notice this before but when a
zombie gets killed in front of another
zombie the zombie behind it gets kind of
splattered with that zombies blood it's
an interesting little addition like a
little bit of detail very very cool get
their legs out come on oh Jesus guys
come on you're not exactly helping oh
god no oh no no no no no no no no no oh
god no oh oh god no no no okay everyone
ignore that ever happened that did not
happen so I'm finally getting back on
track to where I should have been way
before but that's not the case it's
actually it's been weird I've been
playing this over and over in like none
of my games
they've been like I've been like orangey
to hell and back just like terrible
terrible luck on like finding and losing
people and then like getting bad aim and
[ __ ] like that
and it's just like I don't know what it
is this is like for some reason I wasn't
doing nearly as good as I should have
been doing considering I know how to
play this game so I'm just wanting to
pause there for a second
I'm gonna get back to where I was don't
you worry
hey there
why aren't you dying wine tonight went a
nine you should be dying
why aren't you die die [ __ ] die what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what what what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
why oh my god are you [ __ ] kidding me
what the [ __ ] oh my god well there I go
I got the gun
ah and now I'm gonna do the last level
with the Barrett [ __ ] criminy Christmas
this plows three people that I was in
silence for the first part of this I
kinda I've been playing this so long
trying to beat it that I almost forgot
that I was playing it for you guys so
look at the reward that I have read all
my coward buddies that ran away okay
we're leaving you alone it's okay really
ran away in support of your amazingness
cuz we use it in the next video or the
next day you have such a cool weapon bro
to cleave through all your enemies bro
well you and I survived it together burn
oh look we did it burn
all right ahead
barbar oh my gasps ooh Jorge and erotic
erotic
ah babies [ __ ] in the proper choice
words barbers stick with it hey it's
hard to get it is possible but it seemed
to be there we go
got one that's all that mattered not
matter it's like occasionally it'll just
miss like no matter what oh look
rescue thank you we're saved Oh glorious
day bang another zombie shoot him BAM
and that is the last stand I played for
an hour and 41 minutes trying to get
that perfect that was freaking difficult
I don't know why I kept having such bad
luck where I would I eventually honed
the strategy in to get like put all your
resources in just weapons until later
and then then do a big chunk into
survivors and then move from there like
it was just brutal but that is the last
stand it is still one of my favorite
flash games of all time because it's
like even though I was playing it over
and over again I was still having fun
it's a good game it's finely tuned very
hard with lots of play time so play it
for yourself see if you can even get to
the end of it because like I said it's
really hard and there are more games in
the series so if you want to see me play
the other games in the series or any
other games by these developers let me
know in the comments below leave a like
if you enjoyed the video thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you
in the next video